ich werde ihn vermissen
ich vermisse euch auch schon mal wie
weit ich war total aufgeregt weil ich
wusste wie 'das wird passieren' richtig
lang und wenn man sich dann gut ich kann
euch jetzt euch denn aus dem casting
aber man weiß ja nie wie ist das wenn
man dann wirklich so viele tage so viele
stunden am stück miteinander verbringt
und das ist ja alles auch anstrengend
wer morgens früh bis abends spät
gearbeitet dann ist
wenn euch gebracht
dass ich damit nicht gerechnet hat
natürlich immer das hat mich geärgert
dass ich immer so der papa sein musste
jetzt müssen wir noch das machen das
müssen wir das land machen und ich hätte
einfach gerne mit euch
das wird nicht länger bei einem bier
zusammen gesessen oder einfach mal ein
bisschen mehr gequatscht und das wird
mir ein bisschen trotzdem wird mir das
hier fehlen also es war eine
anstrengende zeit angesehen für tolle
führung ihr seid echt tolle typen